[Applause]
[Music]
usually is the only country along with
Greece that is poorer now than before
having the euro as their official
currency the figures leave no space
without italians now have a less
purchasing power than before they joined
the euro which makes them one of the few
countries that became worse off after
joining the European Union
[Music]
we are talking about the second biggest
industrial power in all of Europe which
is only surpassed by Germany in fact
during the 90s the Italians were
wealthier than the British in the French
now if you're my age or older you might
remember eros Ramazzotti luciano
pavarotti or these so-called Spaghetti
Westerns
yes dear viewer Italy was one of the
biggest powerhouses on the planet and
all despite their governments and their
ruling class the political history of
Italy is how should we say it well let's
just say it makes gameofthrones look
like the Gilmore Girls
just remember Italians healthy Sicilian
Cosa Nostra the Calabrese the drain
Greta the Napolitan Kimura and many many
other gangs and yes all of them have
important connections with the highest
levels of politicians but there's more
than just a mafia here during the Cold
War some government officials helped
extreme right-wing terrorist groups that
organized the most violent attacks that
you could imagine and that's not even
talking about the extreme left wing
which didn't exactly stay quiet either
the Red Brigades kidnapped and murdered
an Italian prime minister
look if you're into scary stories you
should Google something about the
propaganda duo or you can just watch the
movie ill Devo from Paolo Sorrentino you
will discover a fascinating country
where politics or anything was boring
and now you might be wondering well what
exactly is going on in Italy today do
they have as much sin stability as they
did in the 1970s and the 1980s and the
answer well absolutely
in just 10 years if you had six
different Prime Minister's 10 years in
other words keeping up with Italian
politics is a pre impossible mission and
this is why in this video we're not
actually going to talk about the Italian
elections that have been celebrated
recently not even about Berlusconi's and
love life oh no because the real
question here is how is it possible that
such a chaotic country could manage to
become quite so wealthy and what is
happening now after two decades of
economic stagnation today we are going
to answer both of those questions but
before we do let's take a look back at
the good the bad and the ugly of Italian
history Giulio Andreotti is the good
during the 1940s the Italian Communist
Party was the biggest of its kind all
across Western Europe with more than 1.3
million members they could win an
election anytime they wanted as you can
imagine in the middle of the Cold War
this was something America could not let
happen so you remember that thing called
the Marshall Plan well if you've been
following visual politic for a long time
you already know that Uncle Sam sent
lots and lots of money to Europe so they
can rebuild their destroyed cities when
it came to Italy this money was not only
meant to help the country but also to
finance the only political party who
could face that communist threat this
party was called Christian democracy
mother save your children from
Bolshevism vote Christian democracy in
the next 50 years Italy had 30 different
Prime Minister's this means that the
average span of an Italian government
was a little more than a year and a half
but they all had something in common
most of them they were Christian
Democrat governments and within the
Christian Democrats is a man that you
should know his name was Giulio
Andreotti and he became prime minister
seven different times and is the real
Godfather of Christian democracy for
years no Italian politician could do
anything without being blessed by Mr
Andreotti power wears out those who
don't have it Giulio Andreotti
so but now the obvious question is well
what did the Christian Democrats stand
for while Christian democracy was
basically what we call a catch-up all
party anyone except communists could
find his or her place inside of this
party and this included deals with
Napolitan Kimura the Sicilian Cosa
Nostra and allegedly extreme right-wing
groups that terrorized the country
during the 1980s but we are going to
talk about all of that in a future video
the important thing here is that
andreotti and his Christian Democrats
badly needed popular support and you
know you need to win some elections
[Music]
in order to do that what's better than
employing people with a good salary you
see Italy has over 3.5 million civil
servants and they're among the highest
paid in the entire world
this means a crazy public spending and
lots of bureaucracy in fact since andrea
sees time until now Italy is famous for
two things red tape and ineffective
course for a better understanding let's
imagine we have a company that produces
construction machines and we have
clients who doesn't pay us naturally we
probably want to take him to court if we
are in say France this process could
take around two and a half months but in
Italy you could wait more than three
years before the problem gets solved as
you might imagine this is not exactly
the best of business climates but
nevertheless I did say that Italy became
one of the wealthiest countries in all
of Europe so how is that possible
[Music]
well dear viewer the answer lies in the
Italian lira yes you heard that right
when they had their own currency the
Italian central bank could devaluate
their currency anytime they needed to
put their economy on steroids
why now you may be wondering well but
Simon isn't this that the worst thing
that you could do for instance in
another video I told you that Germany
became rich partly because they had a
very stable currency the deutsche mark
and now it seems that I'm telling you
the exact opposite I mean how is it
possible that Italy could grow so much
having so much corruption so much red
tape and just constant evaluations well
let's dive in
[Music]
what gorsek freddy is the ugly having
acted in more than 1,700 movies rocco
siffredi AKA the italian stallion
dominated the adult section of rental
stores worldwide during the 1980s and he
is also an interesting symbol of the
Italian economy at that time a growth
model that relied heavily on inflation
you see during the 80s in the 90's italy
flooded the world with cheap products
they were a kind of 20th century china
as soon as something worked in some
other country some italian company would
show up and make the same thing but do
it cheaper let's have a look at an
example american movies in America John
Wayne movies were incredibly successful
logical Hollander be so Italian movie
producers started doing more of the same
but at the industrial level and this is
how these spaghetti western was born at
the same time the exact same thing was
happening with other industries while
Donna Summer was making the entire world
dance aliens struck back with Sabrina
who did the same but cheaper and more
explicitly but what about animated
movies while Disney was launching
Aladdin in movie theatres the cheap
Italian version was already available in
all of the countries video stores
but initially they were cheaply
reproducing more than just culture in
general Italian companies mastered the
art of making cheap things or as
economists would say low added value
manufacturing Italy produced clothes
furniture and plenty of plastic items if
he bought an animated action figure in
the 1990s it probably had a made in
Italy label somewhere but if you bought
a stereo sound system it would have a
made in Germany or made in Japan label
and now the question arises well why was
the Italian economy so strongly based on
selling cheap things abroad well look at
this chart you can see the value of the
Italian lira against the German mark as
you can see during the 80s and 90s
Italian currency was losing value all
the time
in 1980 you could get 450 liras for one
german mark 15 years later you get a
thousand liras for one german mark so
what does this mean means innovation was
way more expensive for Italian companies
than for German ones for instance
imagine we have an Italian production
company during the 1980s and we want to
make a really innovative movie something
like Star Wars with state of the art
special effects and cutting-edge
technology if we want to do that we need
to buy animation software that's
produced in Japan and special cameras
from America but since our Italian
currency is losing value all the time
those things are more expensive for us
and add to this that any time we need to
hire someone new we're having to cut
through never-ending red tape so
suddenly not something's are good is it
[Music]
but now imagine that instead of making a
Star Wars like film we call our friend
rocco siffredi and we make an adult
movie with him we just need a couple of
cameras a room and a pet and since we
have a weak currency we can sell our
movies abroad for a lower price than any
other film so simply following this
model the Italian economy it grew
sky-high during these years thousands of
small companies were born but make no
mistake here Italian s amis had nothing
to do with German SMEs
you see German Mittal status had between
50 and 200 workers and they had enough
scale to invest money on research and
innovation Italian companies were way
smaller their methods were more
traditional and their industries were
well more illegal Italy started taking
account of its shadow economy and found
that it made up a fifth of Italian GDP
as a result the economy grew by 18
percent overnight so now you might
wonder why should Italians innovate so
much if they were doing so well by not
doing it well now I'm gonna tell you why
silvio berlusconi is the ugly
now finally the 21st century Christian
democracy not really that important
anymore now the brand new leader of the
center-right wing is the man you see on
screen now and yes you might know that
his name is Silvio Berlusconi I have
little hair because my brain is so big
it pushes everything else out Silvio
Berlusconi 2002 is not the best year to
be Italian Prime Minister
you know why well because 2002 was the
year Italy abandons the Italian lira and
started using the euro and what's the
main characteristic of the euro
well no government can decide by itself
when they devalue it euros are issued by
the European Central Bank which includes
representatives of all the member
countries this was a big problem for a
country like Italy which had become so
addicted to devaluation but things don't
stop there
maybe you remember another thing that
happens at the beginning of the 2000s
and if you don't well let me refresh
your memory
China joins the World Trade Organization
at last and so now you might be
wondering well what does China have to
do with the Italian economy well as you
might guess rather a lot the fact that
China had joined the World Trade
Organization was a symptom of something
much bigger his men - all of Asia was
flooding the international markets and
it was not only China other countries
like Thailand and Bangladesh were
already becoming big manufacturing
powerhouses and surprise surprise what
did these countries start manufacturing
first well very very cheap things same
as the Italians but even cheaper
back then Germany was already a beer
moths technology-wise so despite the
Asian competition their products they
were still competitive meanwhile Italy
could not go back to old-school
devaluation first they were now part of
the euro and second devaluing wasn't a
solution against Asia's cheap salaries
here's an example one of the most
symbolic Italian companies is Fiat in
1990 they sold over 1.3 million cars in
Europe now they only sell 700,000 and
they can't get into new markets
[Music]
other brands like BMW still maintain
their share on their traditional markets
and also they're growing in emerging
countries like China but just hold on a
minute here because well done yes
you remember how Italy had over three
million civil servants well they are
still there and they still have to be
paid in other words while the Italian
economy is falling and their government
is collecting fewer and fewer taxes they
are still spending the same amount of
money so what does that mean what it
means Italy is now the fourth most
indebted country on the planet
their public debt is over one hundred
and thirty percent of their GDP and this
TIFIA is simply crazy Italy is Europe's
next big problem
so now the question is should Italy
abandon the euro so that they can go
back to their devaluation methods and
cheap manufacturing or maybe they should
follow the German model and let their
companies innovate more well I've said
my piece so I'll just leave it to you to
leave your comments in the section below
and if you are wondering now about how
the German economic model works maybe
you missed our previous video just click
on this one you can see on the screen
now and you'll learn everything you need
to know about Germany's economy there
you go and also don't forget to visit
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
are not mine and as always don't forget
we publish new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button and you will not miss a single
post if you like this video also give it
a thumbs up as always see you next time
and if you want to learn more about
politics and here even more of my lovely
voice you can join us at reconsider
media we have a podcast at reconsider
media.com slash podcast CFA
[Music]